eight news now area 15. it's got some
super cool stuff it seems to have
everything right
this latest installation is no exception
we are looking at what's in store at
meow wolf's omega mart
and you know who is there to show us
around let's send it over to rocky
welcome to america's most exceptional
grocery store these are our first guests
as of today this is the grand opening
everybody's very excited to be the first
shoppers at area 15 at omega mart you've
been
coming through here for the last few
months now and you've been seeing the
outside and wondering what the heck
is inside that area and here it is so
let me talk to the
art director here who's maybe checking
out some bleach are you in need
yeah you know it's on my list so i'm
just here you know running some errands
running some errands because we can do
that here at omegamart what what do you
have to offer
oh so much to offer here at omegamart
really
it's just a bounty of anything you could
ever desire let's name off some products
cause i see soup i see
i feed soap you got your socks you got
your soaps you got your
404 digital augmented reality beauty
products wow wow and okay now my
question is is this stuff actually real
it's real many things are real many
things are
beyond what we could perceive as real
the area 15 way i like it i like it
so how so tell us when people come down
how can we enjoy
all of this uh alternate reality
stuff you can enjoy it by coming with
curiosity safely always
we're gonna ask that you keep a mask on
at all times
social distance whenever possible we
have uh
very uh frequent sanitation policies
and and we're keeping a capacity within
the governor's orders
of course and i would say also enjoying
it safely by not eating the meat product
it is meat product 100 certified
tested meat product okay and
now as we walk down this aisle here i'm
checking out the
milk and the orange juice yeah this
error seems to have occurred don't worry
we're looking into it there's nothing to
be concerned about here okay
okay and also i know as you walk through
and you open some doors you might enter
a new dimension or something like that
there are portals
or openings into other worlds again
you guys can see that they just came out
of the they just came out
of the drink of the drink happening
what's going on here
drink like are you are you sure you saw
what you think you saw
i'm not sure okay guys coming up next
coming up next
at the later in the show i'm definitely
going to check out what's beyond
this door auto mega mart at area 15 you
guys don't want to miss that
very cool well speaking of markets one
just recently opened here in the valley
and it focuses on all things vegan
veggin out market
welcomed shoppers for the very first
time back in december
as more and more people turn to a
plant-based lifestyle
for health reasons veggin out aims to
help those who are curious about it
and also offers a variety of products
it's a small store so everything we have
is vegan it's easy to shop too you don't
have to go and
read the labels everything is is you
know what's going to be 100 vegan
well there you there there there you
heard it he says a lot of those products
are from small businesses
and they're working on ways to get some
of those local items on their shelves as
well
the market is also hosting fido's
vegan hot dogs this weekend and they're
inviting you to stop by that's on
saturday
and sunday from noon to four you can
find out more information on our website
8newsnow.com